welcome to this video black against snow
kit this is a GM right yep okay let's go
for a Sicilian and see what he's got in
store should be five no we actually get
the Kalashnikov variation yeah I don't
really know the theory here and I'd if I
yeah that's not really the best move I
think but don't ask me why exactly I'd
have six I think Jack yeah I think
there's even the idea to sacrifice the
pond if I'm not completely mistaken hmm
can't remember so let's let's just
protect it let's protect it this is
certainly not the best way to play this
line but it should be playable we are
not leading to to any huge problems ok
so just cancels or Bishop g5 immediately
and let's just castle first at least
I've got a better development here I
mean ok so this should be fire for it
if it takes G fun I can i can think of
Bishop of Queen B 6 it's not completely
ridiculous but this is the simpler way
to Player of course okay so he's playing
this in a very very simple fashion
without any any particular yeah ambition
that same I can play rook the aid yeah
let's do that protect the porn what is
of course very solid but I have no
problems whatsoever it's just it's just
about equal okay not sure what the same
quindi three what is this idea I put I'm
a preparing f5 this is why I went into h
8 a-2 when I can take a tune if we go
see for I have 94 it's not clear how
ridiculous it is to take probably this
ridiculous
nah I'm not going to not to ensure to
take out that's really to him too much
so this is a simple way to play
interesting I that's interesting if i
take i have a slight issue with you six
with the open-air farm
hmm yeah it's not it's not so convenient
really nothing special but cheeks don't
have this I can also just go back 95
it's not even not a big problem or
anything but it seems a bit a bit as i
mentioned a bit inconvenient
Jerry I'm as usual the one time okay
cantique or create a five okay just take
it
yeah I played that very very quickly and
didn't make any any obvious mistakes or
anything maybe you can just play okay
Queen a 7-11 knight c6 something like
that
yeah I can mostly I can just sit in way
they can't afford to cannot do much more
I didn't really see that Queen d2 idea
coming not sure of this was for any good
to h6 but ok maybe I have rooted for
this age for movers certainly debatable
this is really giving him anything that
was that was really stupid right why did
I we did I love that I'm okay
still not sure how terrible it really is
i mean it's certainly not not really
great but i'm not so sure how is winning
will be five maybe come check check I
can insert insert this check
but yeah check check biggest issue is
the time the position is spoiled but 20
seconds check check check
check check check grah offered gras yeah
yeah it was a bit lucky because of my
time management and the position wasn't
any good idea I wasn't I wasn't really
having a good good time yeah here I'm
okay but I played it I played it
certainly badly afterwards I don't know
maybe I was a bit too ambitious here is
this this kind of moves I me okay that
that shouldn't be bad yam but I mean
this is this is an idea to play it in a
very simple fashion yeah I had seen this
but seemed a bit weak I mean the idea is
that this is of course completely okay
if I get in d5 and if he goes here and I
can play 97 and this this kind of thing
is very clearly okay for me yeah here
I'm not even I mean not even a fraction
worse or anything I can just just trade
everything often Queen B 6 or whatever
this is completely okay yeah there's
nothing going on so yeah this f5 I mean
I don't really don't know computer wants
to take a two yeah I had the hunch that
hinted might be possible to take but it
looked so ugly I'm this yeah I saw that
but I couldn't really believe it this is
cut off bishop computer says black ass
better here but 0.6 now can I cannot
play that I mean not a human for human
it's not a great idea yeah this was a
good move I cannot really take this
leads to to some problems because I i
would like to play something like King
g8 Bishop e6 but this is of course
ridiculous
now so I had to drop back and to him
yeah yeah i'm just-just were see'em
somewhat question is how much i think he
always kept something but not sure how
bad it really is i mean i'm worse but
how much is probably probably debatable
rook be one was interesting here we're
taking 185 chairman yeah around ta is he
certainly in a very good shape I Eric
see one was stronger okay wind sample
that wins for white now I have no kind
of cut no counter player I have to go
somewhere and he takes yeah this is much
better in comparison he's got the be
porn and I have zero counterplay I'm
still a bit confused though why this is
plus 4 I mean okay white is certainly
clearly better but this is strapped
right not a good position T okay I'm
just the worse but pledges very very
quickly Jim totally unsure of how great
it really is this pawn is also bid week
and it's all on one one side of the
border check chan yeah it's already
already a drawl check kind of weird okay
interesting nevertheless thanks for
watching